meine damen und herren giannina kirsch
ist bei uns im studio und beantwortet
die eine große frage eine große frage wo
ist michael wendler in seiner traum
bilanzen florida ja da ist auf jeden
fall nicht mehr denn dort mussten er und
seine frau laura ausziehen weil der
mietvertrag nicht verlängert wurde wir
hier gestern exklusiv berichtet
natürlich haben wir uns nun auf
spurensuche begeben unter anderem mit
den nachbarn gesprochen und die das kann
ich ihnen jetzt schon verraten lassen
wirklich kein gutes haar an dem sänger
diese villa mit vier schlafzimmern einem
schicken pool und insgesamt
228 quadratmetern grundstück frisch denn
michael wendler und laura müller wurde
der mietvertrag ihrer traumvilla in
südflorida nicht verlängert das erfuhr
bild exklusiv vom vermieter laut bild
informationen ist das ehepaar bereits
ausgezogen und das obwohl die miete
bereits beim einzug bis zum 30 09 2011
22 bezahlt wurde bild reporterin kate
die pfleger sprach mit der nachbarin des
wendlers sie ist die schwester des
vermieters und über den auszug des
ehepaars mehr als glücklich es ist das
haus meines bruders erz an ihn vermietet
und er ist einfach gegangen du weißt
nicht warum es gab einfach keinen grund
er ist einfach gegangen vor ablauf des
mietvertrags wir wissen es nicht und es
ist uns auch egal ist irgendwas passiert
wir wissen es nicht eines tages rief
unser pulver an und sagte er sei weg und
wir waren einfach nur geschockt oh mein
gott wir sind froh dass er weg ist es
war ein alptraum also war ein schlechter
miete kein kommentar
[Gelächter]
doch wo ist michael wendler ja das ist
die große frage erst im vergangenen jahr
kaufte er sich ganz in der nähe ein
grundstück um ein neues haus zu bauen
nach bild recherchen wurde bisher
allerdings noch kein bauantrag für das
grundstück gestellt dort finden die
wendlers also keinen unterschlupf
ja meine kollegin kathy flickr hat
natürlich nicht locker gelassen sie ist
weiter auf wendler suche und natürlich
wollen wir von ihr jetzt wissen wo bist
du gerade ich sehe irgendwie autos im
hintergrund genau ich stehe vor der
camping bird das ist der größte auto das
der größte händler der hier mit
wohnmobilen wohnwagen handelt weil wir
haben einen tipp bekommen und zwar wurde
michael wendler und laura vor zirka zwei
drei monaten dabei gesehen wie sie eine
messe besucht haben von wohnwagen und
wohnmobilen und haben sich dabei sehr
interessiert für ein ganz bestimmtes
modell wir sind hier alles abgefahren
sind von verschiedenen händlern gefahren
jetzt hier die camping gott ist der
größte händler und dort wurde uns
bestätigt von der von dem verkäufer auf
dem haupt verkäufer hier im verkaufsbüro
dass ein michael norbert genau dieses
modell gekauft haben probleme kurz
musste ich einmal kurz unterbrechen für
alle die es euch wissen welcher in
ohrbeck das ist sein echter name wenn
nur ein künstlername das ist ja total
irre also der wurde jetzt bestätigt dass
michael wendler kinowerk sich dort ein
wohnmobil gekauft haben soll hast du
eine ahnung um was für ein modell es
sich da handelt ja genau also was ist
das wohnmobil zieglers das ist ein
standardmodell dass uns das was oft am
meisten gekauft wurde also das ist ein
zweisitzers hat als zwei becken zu zwei
personen hauptsächlich geeignet oder
vielleicht auf ein tolles kind die
beiden haben ja ein hund es gibt eine
dusche und es ist sehr einsetzbar für
roadtrips man kann darin übernachtet man
kann sogar ein zelt anbauen wenn man
jetzt draußen sitzen möchte oder dann
doch irgendwo länger bleiben kann und
das ist nicht ganz so groß aber sie
können damit auch in die stadt fahren
oder kommt somit sogar auch ein
parkplatz und ja das haben sie sich
jetzt hier gekauft also als der micha
norbert michael wendler und das ist
genau das gleiche modell das die beiden
sich vor drei monaten auf dieser
wohnwagen messe angeschaut hat also
katie ich muss sagen wir zeigen du
siehst ist jetzt gerade nicht aber wir
haben gerade dieses modell von dem du
gerade erzählt daß auch gesehen von
innen also ich muss sagen ja riesig
vielleicht nicht aber da kann man schon
drin wohnen wenn man möchte und
möglicherweise gerade keine andere
bleibe hat was kostet denn der spaß
also die standard-version fängt an bei
80.000 dollar es geht dann rauf bis 130
140 1000 dollar es kommt natürlich
darauf an welche extras man möchte die
innenausstattung kann man natürlich
luxuriöser machen oder nur die basic
ausstattung dass es genau wie beim
normalen auto dazu hat er mir allerdings
keine auskünfte gegeben der verkäufer
das ist super wir können dazu nichts
sagen das modell ist aber dass und ja
welches modell sie jetzt gekauft sagen
zu welchem preis das wissen wir nicht
aber
also ohne 2 und bei zahlt man so gut
60.000 dafür hast du gerade gesagt ja
also bei 80.000 80.000 sogar naja also
dafür dass der michael wendler hier in
deutschland ja steuerschulden hat das
wird den gläubigern glaube ich nicht so
ganz so gut schmecken dass er sich jetzt
so ein wohnmobil gekauft haben soll es
könnte natürlich immer noch sein dass es
noch einen anderen michael norberg in
dieser region gibt der sich
möglicherweise für genau das modell
interessiert hat aber davon gehen wir
mal jetzt nicht aus wir haben natürlich
auch michael wendler angefragt da hat
sich aber bisher nicht bei uns gemeldet
hätte ich sag mal hast du irgendeine
vermutung haben die nachbarn die sich ja
sehr darüber freuen dass michael wendler
endlich ausgezogen ist habt ihr
irgendeinen plan wo der sich aufhalten
könnte also die nachbarn haben überhaupt
keine ahnung es war auch er so die
stimmung dass es dieses uns völlig egal
wo er ist ich habe jetzt mit einer
nachbarin gestern die genau gegenüber
von irgendwo und das ist auch eine
deutsche und sie hat gemeinsam sogar ein
paket noch für laura sie warte darauf
dass lauras sie vielleicht noch mal bei
ihr meldet und was jetzt auch gesehen
wurde wir sehen das ja als auch hier
dass laura und michael in new york
gesehen wunder so laura hat fotos
gepostet ob die natürlich das war vor
einer woche zeit gehabt die jetzt noch
da sind ob sie schon weitergefahren sind
ob sie hier man weiß es nicht amerika
ist riesengroß und mit zum wohnmobil ist
man natürlich auch sehr flexibel und
kann dann in jede richtung fahren
absolut per die du bleibst weiterhin für
uns an den fersen von michael wendler
und seiner laura vielen dank für diese
spannenden informationen das ist ja
wirklich irre wir haben ja jetzt
eigentlich nur zwei optionen entweder
der wendler der macht urlaub in dem
wohnmobil oder möglicherweise hat er
eine neue bleibe auf
vier rädern danke dir gerne dankeschön